[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt die potenz muskulatur
weil erektions störungen auch krankhafte
ursachen haben können ist eine
gründliche untersuchung wichtig eine
erektion wird durch reizung der penis
nerven ausgelöst dabei sorgen
botenstoffe dafür dass vermehrt blut in
die schwellkörper fließt wodurch sie bis
zu viermal größer werden als sonst
der penis wird hart beim männer mit
erektionsproblemen ist dieser vorgang
gestört nicht selten sind
erektionsstörungen noch vorboten von
gefäßerkrankungen herzinfarkt und
schlaganfall
deshalb überprüft professor sommer auch
die durchblutung im penis wir haben in
deutschland eine sehr große studie
gemacht und haben hier herausgestellt
dass jeder fünfte mann unter einer
erektilen dysfunktion leidet und das ist
eigentlich eine richtige volkskrankheit
aber kaum jemand redet darüber oder
möchte gerne darüber reden